تركنا مواقع
الانقاذ حيث حيث الدفاع المدني يعمل على
استخراج الضحايا او يعمل على انتشال
العالقين من تحت الانقاض واتينا الى احد
المواقع حيث المدنيون المتضررون من
الزلزال يفترسون الطرقات يفترشون حافه
الطرقات في عده مناطق بريف حلب وهنا في
ريف عفرين في هذا المكان تشاهدون هذه
العوائل كيف تجلس هنا على الارض تماما
بعضهم حظي بغطاء واخرون من دون اي شيء من
دون طعام من دون تدفئه من دون اي شيء على
هذه الطرقات ينتظرون المساعدات قبل قليل
كان هنالك سياره وزعت عليهم شيئا من الخبز
حظيت به بعض العائلات وعائلات اخرى خرجت
خاليه الوفاض من الخبز
الان مع اقتراب ساعات الليل نحن نرى بان
الطقس اصبح اكثر بروده وهؤلاء الاطفال هنا
على حافه الطرقات يعانون النساء خصوصا
معظم العائلات هنا من النساء ومن الاطفال
حتى المنظمات المحليه العامله هنا في
الداخل السوري تقول بانها هي لا تستطيع ان
تواكب هذه الكارثه الكبيره ولابد ان تدخل
اليها
الامدادات من خارج سوريا حتى تقوم بتوزيع
هذه المساعدات على هؤلاء
النازحين هذا المنظر ممتد على نحو خمسه
كيلو متر على طول هذا الطريق لذلك كما
تقول المنظمات وكما يقول الدفاع المدني
هنا لابد ان تكون هنالك سواء حمله اغاثه
دوليه كبيره او حتى جهود دوليه تكون على
حجم الكارثه الكبيره التي يعيشها هؤلاء
المدنيون